the reason the seventh sea of YouTube
success is so important is because
YouTube burnout is real and you might
find that that day you get monetized
you're like dear God took a lot of
energy to get this far you're sweating
you're exhausted and so the seventh sea
of YouTube success consistency is all
about building routines and systems so
that you can avoid burnout and build a
lasting Creator career
welcome back to the think media podcast
my name is Sean Cannell and we've been
talking about the seven C's of YouTube
success and in the first episode of this
two-part series we talked about Courage
the first C and how you got to get that
mindset right you got to build your
boldness you gotta really punch fear in
the face and press record and in this
episode we're going to go into the
second six C's of YouTube success but
today's episode is brought to you by
ytsecrets.com the second edition of
YouTube Secrets is out now if you are a
book reader you can grab it at the
website or on Amazon ebook is available
as well or audible if you like audio
books and I'll talk a little bit more
about that later but let's dive into
part two of the seven C's of YouTube
success so after getting 200 million
views on YouTube and posting over 2 000
videos Plus testing out some of my tips
and strategies with thousands of
creators I have formulated a system
called the seven C's of YouTube success
and I talk about that more in my book
YouTube Secrets the second edition is
out now but in this podcast episode I
want to focus on the next six steps and
I'll break down and give you a quick
recap on all seven and these are going
to help you whether you're just starting
you haven't started yet or if you want
to scale your YouTube channel to the
next level this formula is really going
to serve you and this is part two we go
more into the first C which is courage
in part one of course before you start
you've got to punch fear in the face and
press record you've got to start before
you're ready and you really have to have
the mindset to overcome the fear of what
other people think and if you want a
little bit more on that I highly
recommend going back to part one of this
series but let's recap now and go
through all seven number one is courage
number two is Clarity start with the end
in mind when you're starting a YouTube
channel or even if you're further along
you want to have really strong answers
to these questions what is your Channel
about you know the problem people have
is I don't know what to make my Channel
about what topic should it be about this
is a good question or think deeply about
not just is there an audience for it but
what are your skills and strengths what
will keep you fascinated and curious
another question under Clarity is who is
your channel for the mistake people make
is they try and reach everybody they
think man my channel is a gift to the
world you know what I mean like I am
God's gift to humanity and ultimately
everyone should watch my channel what
I've learned is there's no channel that
everyone in the world wants to watch
what's better is actually having a
specific audience because if you try and
reach everybody you'll end up reaching
nobody but when you know exactly who
your channel is for then you can get a
lot of traction and the next question is
you know what's your YouTube business
plan too many people don't think this
through they think about just starting
the channel and how do I get views I'd
like to think or I'd like to ask okay
how am I going to make money from this
what's the long-term plan for this you
know the longer term term you think into
the future the longer the time Horizon
that you reverse engineer your YouTube
channel back from like what does winning
look like in five or ten years how would
you feel if we were having this
conversation a couple years from now
what would have had to have happened in
your life in your family in your
business in your bank account and on
your YouTube channel for you to be just
pumped with the results like think about
that that gives you an end Target that
you can work backwards from this is the
second C of YouTube success Clarity you
got to start with the end in mind and
I've learned that the riches are in the
niches so it's powerful to ultimately
get clear on having a clear channel
topic a clear person which we would call
kind of like an avatar of who your
channel is for and getting clear on what
do do you do how do you do it and why do
you do it now again of course I'm
throwing a lot at you and I'm just going
to give you kind of an overview of the
seven C's of YouTube success I highly
recommend
um checking out the the book for um
in-depth walkthrough of each of these
and kind of a recap of all these
questions but after you've punched fear
in the face with courage and after you
have gotten clear on what your end goal
for your YouTube channel is number three
is you got to set up your Channel
channel is the third C of the seven
see YouTube formula so you got to set
your channel up and this is as simple as
going to Google and saying start a
YouTube channel and you got to have a
Gmail address you set your channel up
you got to pick a name this is the home
of your content right and so
um you know how do I start a YouTube
channel YouTube will walk you through
that it's free the steps are all there
but you know what are the best practices
of setting up a YouTube channel and if
you haven't done maybe like spring
cleaning on your channel in a while make
sure you have a good Avatar that's
either a picture of your face or a
picture of your logo for your brand a
strong channel name a good cover image
you want to link up your website if you
have one or maybe a link to your email
list a newsletter that you have a free
gift you give away as a business owner
you're collecting leads you want to have
links to your social media accounts fill
out your about page connect an email so
people can get in touch with you and
then after you've posted content the way
you organize your YouTube channel is
with videos in playlists and so
ultimately the home page of your YouTube
channel is not just your uploads you can
select a channel trailer you can select
what non-subscribers see new people to
your Channel That's typically a channel
trailer and you can select a video that
returning subscribers see
all those different things can
eventually build your channel up that
sounds overwhelming if you're just
starting and the first thing you want to
do is just get it started like just set
it up get it going you can improve it
and decorate as you go the next one is
content and that is now you're going to
start uploading to your channel and the
goal is to make videos that people love
to watch and you might be wondering well
how do I make videos at all and I would
encourage you just start grab your
smartphone it's a great place to start
on our think media channel our main
Channel Heather Taurus and I did a
series all about how to make a YouTube
video with your smartphone only from
start to finish recording the video
editing the video on your phone creating
a thumbnail on your phone and uploading
everything just from your phone Nolan
and Omar now have done an entire series
Nolan's got a series and we'll link
these up in the show notes uh no one's
got a series on setting up your channel
which we were just talking about and
Omar's got tons of videos on how to make
content so we have lots of free content
that'll help you with these kind of
YouTube Basics to get things going and
some of the questions you might ask
though is again what camera and gear
should I use and again subscribe to our
think media channel how do I outline a
video what types of videos actually get
views and how do I edit videos and what
are the best video formats for getting
views and making money now I can't cover
all this in this you know episode that's
why I wrote an entire book with my
friend Benji about it and that's also
why we have an in-depth online course
called video ranking Academy but I kind
of want to give you a 30 000 foot view
of these building blocks of YouTube and
those are some of the things you should
be thinking so as you have mustered the
courage to start gotten clear on what
your channel is about who it's for
you've started your channel you got you
got it set up you have uploaded one or
two or five videos or just one you've
started posting con content over time
the next C is community your goal is to
build a community of super fans YouTube
is not a one-way conversation the
mindset you need to know is it's not
just a place you want to post content
it's a place where over time now maybe
not when you're starting you might say I
haven't got a comment on my videos yet
but over time you're going to start
seeing a community form especially when
you really study the best practices of
building Community you know one of the
books we recommend in addition to
YouTube Secrets is a book from my friend
Pat Flynn called super fans and it
really goes deep into this community see
it's like you know how do you actually
really make meaningful connections and
intentionally build a community and one
of the things on our community is also
this idea
of the of the idea that you don't need a
large community
the myth is I need a million subscribers
to ultimately make a living or make
serious money on YouTube I know I need a
100 000 subscribers for this to be a
substantial thing or for me to even feel
legitimate it's not true you actually
only need a thousand true fans what does
that mean from a monetary standpoint if
there's a thousand people that
essentially transact a hundred dollars
with you per year
then that's a hundred thousand dollars a
year
and that doesn't mean necessarily that
you have to create a product it simply
means that if a thousand people whether
you link to some affiliate links they
they click on those and it adds up to
100 over 12 months for one person you
know if if you have enough views to get
a little bit of AdSense coming in if you
were to create a 100 product and a
thousand people now maybe you have five
thousand subscribers
but a thousand people are true fans
then that's the math a thousand people
essentially transact a hundred dollars
with you in a year's time that's a six
figure income
and this point is not even about money
it's just about depth it's about the
fact that stop thinking you need 400 000
subscribers what you really want is
Meaningful connections with the focused
group of people and your goal here is
just to care deeply and to connect with
the viewer
speaking of money I've learned this
that's your income is directly
correlated to the amount of value you
add to the marketplace
so if you focus on adding value first
starting a channel that's valuable and
helping viewers get results or be
entertained
the byproduct of that is that you will
have significant income so if you can go
out and create content that really
connects with and serves a thousand
people and think about it this way it
doesn't have to be a hundred dollars
imagine if it was fifty dollars per
person that's 50k in a year imagine if
it was twenty five dollars per a
thousand true fans that's 25
000
that could be extra and again I don't
even need to bring up money on this
point I just mean depth because your
income's correlated to the amount of
value you give
it's it's it's a result of really
serving really entertaining really
educating and people's reciprocity
towards that is they are grateful and as
you give them opportunities to support
you on patreon or buy me a coffee or
YouTube channel memberships uh or you do
an online event or you do a meet up or
you sell merch there's all these
different ways to do it it's just that
relationship with the viewer that's
going to be everything that relationship
with the listener and so the goal here
is to go the extra mile to build
relationships Foster community and make
meaningful connections
the next C now is cash
after you've set up the channel and a
community starts to form you know we say
you got to build your influence income
and so you can ultimately make an impact
you know Community is that influence
piece when zero people are watching zero
money is coming in
but as your influence grows your
following grows now your goal is to
monetize your content in multiple ways
here's a question I like to ask based on
your niche
meaning based on the topic of your
Channel
and the specific style of content you're
creating
what is the shortest path to revenue
maybe put it another way what is the
shortest path to significant Revenue
what do I mean by significant Revenue I
mean what is the shortest path to your
desired
income Target
monthly
let me simplify if you'd say Sean like
how much money do you need or do you
want to live on in a month so that you
could hire more people quit your job and
go full time or start making a part-time
income on YouTube like get clear on that
Target
I need 2 500 a month seven thousand
dollars a month I really want to
generate thirty thousand dollars a month
because if I do that then I could rent
out this space and build out this studio
and hire this team so it's it's a
personal question
but what's the shortest path to get
there
see depending on your Niche you might
say well I'm kind of doing this like
comedy channel to entertain people and
my goal is to get it as big as possible
the shortest path might be you really
focusing on videos that are going viral
because you want to get AdSense and you
want a lot of views to work with maybe
like wider generic Mass Market Brands
like you want to work with a toothbrush
company well it needs to be just pretty
general you know whereas the flip side
is maybe you're in more of a high ticket
Consulting type of a niche and so you
actually are like I just need a couple
hundred people that are very specialized
and if I could get three clients a month
then I could reach my Revenue targets so
what is the shortest path to revenue for
you that's a good way to think about it
and then ultimately your goal is to tap
into the 10 different ways to earn money
from your YouTube channel there's more
than 10 but I break down 10 in the book
and so uh that would be your goals to
think about which are the best of those
10 you know serve you the most all right
and then number seven
is consistency
after you mustered the courage to start
and you get clear about what your end
goal is and then you start your channel
and then you post a few videos one one a
week for four weeks
one a week for three months one a month
for the last six months you're doing the
best you can getting as many videos as
you can you're seeing a little bit of
growth you got some subscribers coming
in you're seeing people leaving some
comments maybe you really went like you
really hustled and you you've posted
like as many videos you can seven days a
week your post you did a 30 day
challenge you're posting as many videos
as you can you're starting to post
YouTube shorts you know you've seen a
little bit of money coming in you just
got monetized you've been hustling you
got a couple clicks on your affiliate
links some money's coming in
the reason the seventh C of YouTube
success is so important
is because
YouTube burnout is real
and you might find that that day you get
monetized you're like dear God took a
lot of energy to get this far you're
sweating you're exhausted and so the
seventh C of YouTube success consistency
is all about building routines in
systems so that you can avoid burnout
and build a lasting Creator career
and so the questions you should be
thinking about are how do I get more
done in less time how do I create more
content with less energy what is the
mindset do I that I need to stay
consistent
another way to put that would be am I
intentionally building mental toughness
to to stay consistent on YouTube through
the highs and the lows am I building
stability in my emotions to be able to
press through the quitting points that
get a lot of people stuck in their
YouTube career over years of creating
content what are the rhythms of
effective content creators you know and
how am I committing to continuous
learning growth and reinvention so that
I don't actually get stuck and maybe
have 15 minutes of YouTube success but
because I didn't reinvent myself or
constantly evolve my Channel or my
strategy or my systems or the way I'm
spending my money or the way I'm you
know building a team or delegating or
hiring
as money starts coming in these are all
big questions and you might be thinking
wow this YouTube thing it goes a little
bit deeper than I thought like I was
just trying to upload a few hobby videos
listen here at think media we are
committed to helping you not just
succeed on YouTube we want to help 10
000 purpose-driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with YouTube and experience that success
without losing their soul
what does that mean it means that you
don't just succeed in YouTube monetarily
or with a lot of subscribers but then
you're burnt out you know you blow up
your relationships you you you're
exhausted you're in pain you know like
it means that you've created cadences
and rhythms and that you continue to
learn and grow and it also it doesn't
mean that you just you hit that success
for 12 months but then you go into a
plateau and a death spiral like how do
you continue to stack success and not
just compromise to get a little traction
and then lose everything and lose your
soul in the process you know what I mean
and so it's not easy that's why we
created this podcast like you gotta be
serious about this thing constantly
thinking about sharpening the ax
constantly thinking about learning and
leveling up pacing yourself having a
good work ethic a good study ethic but
also a good rest ethic
so that she could be in this thing for
the Long Haul and what you'll notice
about the seven C's of YouTube success
is they're not just like a start and an
end point they're actually a continuous
cycle
that you want to return to again and
again I've learned that I have to
continue to go back to the beginning and
and develop a new level of Courage for
the challenges I'm facing today courage
to scale my business courage to risk
investing in team members and hiring and
am I going to be able to keep them on
payroll and can I balance the budget or
courage to be bold when cancer when
culture is trying to cancel people
courage to share my opinion when haters
are leaving negative comments courage to
continue to press forward I am
continually seeking Clarity I'm
continually thinking about okay where is
this going where are we going next where
are we going
um the law of navigation in the 21
irrefutable laws of leadership that's
another one we'll link up you know check
out YouTube Secrets super fans and if
you haven't been studying John Maxwell
21 irrefutable laws of leadership the
law of navigation is it's the leader's
job to chart the course where's this
going where are we navigating to and a
good Navigator is thinking about a lot
of things do we have supplies on the way
what are the supplies Depots where are
we getting gas gas prices are going up
how are we budgeting for that you know
like you're thinking about should we
should we take the highway or should we
take back roads you know are you a
Google Maps per person or are you a Waze
person you know what I mean if you're an
underground Back Road ninja if you have
the Waze app on your phone Clarity
charting the path and this is a cycle
that we continually go back to hey do we
need to update the channel have I
created my playlist lately you know do I
need to clean up some videos there's
some videos that should just be unlisted
or private
um you know what's the experience on the
channel is the cover art even accurate
you know what our think media podcast
channel to this day
we're like two years into this and
there's a random picture from our event
like 2019 and it's still our cover art
like that's that's on my to-do list and
here we are we're 23 people at think
media and we have not updated the cover
art of our very think media podcast
channel so I hope you feel like you're
in good good hands I mean you're in
you're in like-minded company if you're
feeling a little bit overwhelmed hey one
step at a time one thing at a time and
that's why we want to give you
Frameworks like this as just reminders
to go back to uh to continuously be
improving your channel we've learned
small tweaks lead to Giant Peaks and so
I want to constantly be thinking about
how do I you know maybe improve my cover
art is it leading to the right website
link Are My Links dead I do Channel
reviews all the time people's links are
dead like the main thing of their
business doesn't even work so you want
to audit your channel you want to say
how can I improve my content you want to
say am I really taking time to connect
with my community every week our team
now does what's called love bombs on
Wednesday for at least 15 minutes and we
all just devote time to go into our DMS
our YouTube comments on multiple
channels now our Facebook groups our
email inboxes there's a lot happening at
think media but we say listen we have to
always stay in touch with our community
can't just be pushing out content we
need to let people know we love them we
need to say thank you we need to
actually be engaged and we have to do it
in a systematic basis my friend Pat
Flynn author of super fans every Friday
goes on a walk and sends people audio
messages now these are off platform
YouTube doesn't not you do that but he
goes to Instagram and he sends the easy
to send audio messages thanking people
who've sent him a DM or connecting with
people that are following him but that's
Community stuff because what you'll find
is that your community will expand
outside of just YouTube onto other
social media platforms that's something
you keep doing you don't just do it once
you got to keep getting cash you need
money for the mission you can't just get
cash once you got to keep getting it and
then you got to keep staying consistent
and thinking about what are the routines
for a new season you know as at the time
of recording uh I got a two-year-old and
I got one that's days away and so I need
new routines and new systems for a new
season when I was no kids it was
different when I was single it was
different when you're married two kids
it's different you're listening to this
you're like I'm married 10 kids that's
different you need different systems for
consistency my friend keep working the
seven C's of YouTube success
in this episode I've been doing a 30 000
foot flyover of the Seven Seas but I
encourage you to pick up the book or
grab the audiobook and to really immerse
yourself in these principles this is an
unbreakable framework this is a cycle
that we as creators need to continually
go through and I've kind of learned this
I study not just so that I know
something I study so that I never forget
that's why I love repetition and so as I
continually think about tweaking and
mastering these seven C's I find that my
results on YouTube in proof and so
immerse yourself in this content I
really believe you're going to love the
book plus there's so many other there's
new chapters there's like 90 pages of
new content oh there's a whole appendix
with all kinds of listed out resources
tips on getting started with video
editing and cameras and direct links to
a whole series on all kinds of free
tutorials you're really going to love
the book and one ask if you've been
getting value out of this podcast is one
if you've read the book it would mean
the world to me if you'll have to review
on Amazon as an author you know Benji
and I wrote this uh in 2018 and then the
rewrite and the update came in 2022 and
as authors
um one of the most meaningful things you
could ever do to kind of say thank you
is leave a review just to hear your
thoughts your feedback and then secondly
is if you share this with somebody
whether you share the book with somebody
buy it as a gift for somebody
potentially or just share this episode
with somebody again we're always here to
serve you whether you want the book or
not cool but I hope these seven C's of
YouTube success really help you go
further faster in accomplishing your
goal of winning on YouTube this is the
think media podcast and I can't wait to
connect with you in the next episode we
will talk soon
thank you